I want to start the talk actually
mentioning that this is a super
experimental talk
um very
um
experimental and so and and live uh with
lots of live demos so hopefully I will
not break the demo gods and
um and we'll make it happen if not uh
you know silently cheer uh or clap I
will not hear you but anyway support it
as if you can
um so I want to start talking about
Python and
um one thing that is pretty obvious is
that python is very popular today
um and it's not it wasn't that uh
through all the history of python uh
when I started using python it was
around 2001 and 2002. you can see how it
was not the most popular language in the
world it was pretty much down the bottom
and through history uh and through those
years many events led to python being
adopted more and more in specific
communities and python had this
interesting history of being adopted to
by specific
communities that then helped uh increase
the language and popularity and things
like that uh you know I think a big
change was when we found um join Google
uh a lot of people started looking at
python as as a serious programming
language if it was backed by Google it
was easier to actually sell other
companies that it was a language that
was worth exploring it and stuff like
this but one question that is strikes is
actually how is it possible especially
today if we think about
python itself and it it honestly doesn't
have a great story for the two the most
popular Hardware framework or platform
and the most popular software platform
in the world
um Hardware uh you know the most the
most
um uh used type of Hardware today is
mobile phones tablets and things like
this and python doesn't really have a
straightforward story about it
and the same applies for software the
the most popular operating system if we
will in in the world today is the
browser every uh every computer phone
tablet has one and runs applications on
top of it python doesn't really have a
story for python on the browser
um so the the it's it's quite
interesting that it is the most popular
uh language
um programming language in the world
today uh and I will not touch on why and
you know uh but it's a hint is that it's
it's
built to welcome users and it's built to
make things easier
um but anyway moving to the topic of the
Talk itself
um wouldn't it be cool if you could run
python on the browser
um and that's the whole idea about uh Pi
script so uh usually at this part of the
talk I would ask uh who who knows about
five script who had never heard about it
Etc about being
um
remote we'll we'll get straight into the
agenda
um so we'll talk a little bit about Pi
script what it is what it's not how does
it look like things like this uh
specifically we'll touch about we touch
on the pi script for data science and
what is possible today what people have
been doing so far Etc and show a lot of
a few demos and examples
so the first disclaimer is python is
extremely uh new and early in its
history uh and it's it's very Alpha and
other development so if you're if you be
exploring things with pi script and we
should you should uh be advised that we
may change things and between releases
things may break uh um Etc so
and I really want to highlight that uh
make sure you remember uh even this talk
is highly experimental uh just like Pi
script so uh I want to stress that out
but first of all what is pi script
um python Pi script is a platform that
enables uh people to run python on the
browser easily and not only by the
python a version of python but most of
the Python ecosystem on the browser
thanks to piadite
um which is a implementation of of
python for our for on top of scripting
but we'll touch on that later
um it is python with JavaScript it's not
an alternative it's not uh you need you
don't need to choose one or another uh
if they interact with each other uh it
has the concept of environment
management uh Etc and and much more
we'll touch on those later on in the
talk
but why first of all uh well why not I
would say that's the first answer
um but also if if you know given what I
mentioned about
um
about python its popularity it's very
clear
um actually Russell Keith McGee had a a
really great pycon keynote talking about
it you know and how unpredictable events
May change python path and its
popularity and as a community we should
be thinking Advanced and be thinking you
know how
um uh how current how uh up to the times
python is and what we can do to actually
improve the language so that it lasts
for a long time and I think Pi script is
in that vein looking at the future and
the next Generations
um
but looking at five script uh at a
glance
um Pi script itself is is aims to be
very clean and lean and
it's basically the experience is
basically the same as you would do just
writing HTML and and creating a new
website oral web app
um you can add python directly to the
Dom you can add python uh with external
files uh it's aimed to be very
um flexible
we want to make sure that we can bring
the whole ecosystem of python to the
browser uh and basically we want to
empower people we want to democratize
data science and programming uh so
basically we want to bring programming
to the 99
um we want to make sure that the web is
a friendly and hackable place uh we in
the Tech Community we've been looking at
a lot at performance and optimizing
things oftentimes making things more
complicated like server-side and
client-side architecture or making
things super fast at the expense of
being able to just run something or
create a program out of nothing very
fast
um so we want to Target that as well
so what do I need to get started with
advice with Vice script uh reality you
just need you don't need really to
install anything other than your browser
and then you just need to add those two
lines to your page uh your HTML page
when you're authoring it and that should
do the trick
um we after the launch at pycon this
year we we went through changes and
stuff we added a versioning uh system
for pi script
um or a version pattern and we've been
releasing with the new versions and we
you can use latest to actually
um
use the latest released version of I
script we also have a a pointer to alpha
alpha is the version that we launched uh
doing pycon
and we'll not change that and mostly
because a lot of people uh were trying
it and we didn't want to break
um things under on their their nose
you can also use unstable which is
basically updated every time we do a
commit it we would be basically a
nightly version where you get access to
the latest features and stuff like that
but there there's a like
um there's a likelihood that things
might be broken because we didn't go
through the whole testing of an entire
release and then you have the option of
to be in a version and that is what you
should do
um actually you should do even with your
own python projects just just you know
traditional python you should pin your
versions of your dependencies and that's
the same for pi script so if you're
trying Pi script use the use use that
one
uh in the last month's uh since we
launched we launched about six six
months ago
um that the ecosystem around it has
evolved as well some of the
um the editors uh like uh pycharm or
Visual Studio code have support for it
somehow
um which is very cool and we hope that
we'll we'll keep growing and uh make the
the user experience easier and better
um so let's talk about how to Pi script
actually
um as you can see it the experience
itself is pretty much just
um like authoring a web page you just
add your HTML elements and things like
this you add your Pi script dependencies
you can do whatever you you were used to
doing the page and then to run python
you just need to add the pi strip tag
and write your code within that tag
I know a lot of people will say it has
PHP Vibes and I I have to confess it's
kind of true uh which is not great if
you look at things just from a uh from
the surface and and at a quick glance
and we're very opinionated about PHP and
how it differs from python
um
and I want to make sure that you know we
touched on this
um as an Italian uh pizza and pineapple
pizza are is a topic that is close to my
heart uh and I will say that we are not
joining the dark side we are not five
script is not PHP is not intended to be
PHP
um and there are a bunch of reasons and
you know that is
putting python code with the code within
the tag is an option that we wanted to
allow users because it's just fast quick
and we can play with the code that uh
shouldn't be
what you do when you have Pi script code
that you want to run
in production or seriously you should be
you should be using the source attribute
that allows you to actually write python
files and load them through the pi
script tag that is not not only well
because we're not PHP but also because
it's it's way more maintainable it's
easier to test your your code it's
easier to author your code through
syntax highlighting and things like this
um and
um also
differs and and with with PHP not only
from from that side of things but also
the full
um you know namespace management
different scoping and it's python itself
um you know so the differences are uh
not only the you know uh make um
makeup or you know just from the
perspective of seeing a tag on the on
the HTML code
um how about Pi script and JavaScript
um one when we launched power script Pi
script we had a lot of social media uh
heat and a lot of people were asking
actually is is well is is Javascript bad
now or is it a threat to JavaScript blah
blah blah you know the overall idea that
we want to promote is actually that Pi
script plays really well together with
JavaScript and it's actually a a win-win
for both ecosystems
um you know all of a sudden uh
python users can use JavaScript modules
and technology that they were not able
to do before and at the same time uh
JavaScript developers can use part of
the Python ecosystem on the browser they
can use numpy pandas and things like
this they it was not possible
um so anyone actually thinking that you
know a pi script is a drop in
replacement for for JavaScript that's a
very
different opinion than uh the password
team has
um I want to stress uh I'll talk a
little about the platform I've been
mentioning Pi script as a platform not
as a framework and the reason for that
is that
um well I'll touch it on that uh in a
second but I want to also want to quote
Peter Wang who's who presented Pi script
at pycon is a co-creator of pipescript
with me
um and Talking he he mentioned something
like you know a system built on top of
plugins from the start and get going is
usually is often an indication that
Engineers didn't know really what they
needed to do or how the system should
work and so they add the concept of
plugins to delegate that decision and
you know
I want to make sure that
um
uh I want to talk about this because
it's true
um in most time in most in a lot of
cases uh but it's also true that we
thought about plugins from the beginning
not because we didn't know what to do uh
but mostly because the surface of things
that are possible to do and the
um the thing opening a new
uh channel for python users to use the
browser as their their medium will will
not be able to cover everything our
users need so it makes a lot of sense
for us to build a strong platform that
enables Frameworks on top of it so
I've been using platform as a system
that allows users to create Frameworks
while Frameworks are really systems that
allow users to create applications and
showing that uh real quick uh in terms
of Pi script you know if we look at it
as a framework uh it's a piece of
software that allows users to create Pi
script applications using that framework
that framework uses a whole ecosystem
that was available and like piadite and
or micropython for python interpreter
that relies on wasm and M scripting and
it provides apis and all of that is is
run by the browser
if we look at it at the lenses with the
lenses of a platform and that's what we
want to achieve is that actually we want
to allow users to power users to
actually create Frameworks uh that then
allow users to create applications let
it be I don't know a framework that
allows you to create websites very fast
or a framework that allows you to create
uh presentations like this slideshows or
a framework that allows you to create
chat Bots very fast things like that
uh
well
again I want to highlight especially on
this plugins part uh everything is very
uh in progress so expect things to
change and things to improve but also
things to Break
um I want to look at real quick some of
the features of Pi script related to
data science uh but to do that let's
look at the architecture real quick as
you've guessed before 5 script uh sits
on top of a mini layers that were there
we sit on top of shoulders giant
shoulders those Giants are the community
projects that made it happen uh the
easier ones to to look at for biascript
you know uh Pi script provides a layer
on top of iodide piadite itself provides
python the packages an interface the
JavaScript Etc uh pylon uses vams script
and as a layer to communicate with plasm
and actually compile CPAC C pipelines
who has it
um and one very specific thing that is
important for this community in the pi
data communities that seeing uh the
browsers unique and beauty is virtual
machines machine actually help us Target
the problem of reproducibility of data
science and how can I run my code the
same way I ran on my machine on other
machines if we use the browser as this
common layer then we have a very
powerful layer that can we can leverage
and and and use that we know is able to
reproduce the same results
um really quick because I want to really
want to show the demos uh this is how
the Pi Pi script looks like it uses
piadite under the hood uh if I was to
use just piadite
um well
let me skip this one if I also use just
iodide this is how it looks like when to
install packages load packages and then
to to run apart a piece of code a python
piece of code and here it is uh in pi
script all you do you create a
configuration file or a tag where you
add your dependencies and things like
this and then you just write your python
code within tag
uh pioscript also provides an uh element
that is pi rapple that allows you to
actually code in the browser real quick
uh and so as an example let me show uh
if you ever saw the
uh the anti-gravity more uh module you
should be familiar with it with if not
you should open your python interpreter
and type import anti-gravity and you'll
see that it pops up this nice comics in
the browser well Pi script is in the
browser so we thought we could do a
little better uh or cooler and we could
do things interactively so if I do an
important anti-gravity and then I do and
to grab a
fly we can actually make it fly in real
time and you know use the power of the
browser
but more than this we can actually also
run python uh in the browser to create
simulations and use data science tools
so if I execute this code I can actually
display a matplotlib doing this
triangulation
now let's let's go and look at more
demos
so
um
we have a lot of demos on the website
you should check it out uh some I'm
focusing on some of these here uh map a
lot live Seaborn Etc okay we'll we'll
see them
uh so the first one actually this is not
an image this is actually a application
that is running uh on on this slideshow
and is actually displaying this chart uh
using scikit-learn to export a wine data
set and then leveraging pandas plotting
to generate this Matrix of features
another example sorry this is how the
code looks like we defined the
dependencies with the pi config tag
um which by the way we just changed the
interface and we are changing packages
and how you define those but we look at
that later uh and then I just write
python code and that's and that's all I
need to do
um
same thing here this is not an image
this is a plot that is showing the
correlation on the same wine data set
using Seaborn
um and I also want to do some live demos
so and actually display a lot of the
cool work that the community has been
doing
um so
here uh let me show
this live Dion Castillo uh tweeted a
month or two ago hey I'm I built this
interactive uh cheat sheet uh pandas
cheat sheet to to teach users how to
learn pandas and it runs on the browser
um and
you can Define operations that you want
to try out and it has a specific data
set that is already loaded and it it
shows a snippet of code that you need to
run for specific operations and then you
just use them
now you can see how
all of a sudden Pi script enables very
powerful education paths uh paths and
patterns and how it can be used by uh
you know package creators to you know
help their Community learn faster uh
Dylan Castillo also created this
database cookbook where we can compare
how uh plotting would look like
differently with different plotting
libraries uh like if I want to do a
scatter plot with pandas I would put
this way
sorry I copied instead of running
and if I do with Seaborn that would be
different
um
uh back to more Community coolness
Jeff glass uh who's been uh doing a lot
of great work and actually just recently
became a pi script core developer
tweeted a bunch of quick cool examples I
want to show this one which is really
cool
um he basically wrote a pi script app
that uses a rich rich is a client is a
rich text library for the terminal uh
actually if you haven't used it to to
write cli's you should it's amazing uh
but in in interestingly a lot of the
constructs that it has for the console
the terminal actually work on the
browser so if I want to add a bar a
loading bar this is how I do if I want
to have a highlighter an ex an exception
uh all those things would render on this
on the terminal they render just nicely
on the browser
um and I want to show a couple that are
really cool
um this is actually a creating a table
to show a movie list
live
this other one is created as showing a
dynamic progress of whatever it is this
is a simulation
or you can actually use it uh you know
you can use a mix of Pi script write
elements right at the Dom in the Dom
with with the rich itself
now running for the sake of time I also
want to show a lot of the cool examples
that Philip and the panel team created
using pi script and piadite so for
instance this is an application that
runs on the browser and allows us to
interact with data
using panel everything is running on the
browser they also have a cool
exploration panel that allows us to
change
data sets and explore data live
a deck GL
example that allows us to run a
simulation of The Game of Life
thank you very much um I would like you
to I would like you to know that you
have five minutes left for question and
answers
yes let me let me just
do one thing real quick
I wanna uh
show real quick two things one
typescript uh now supports uh well we're
in the process of also supporting
micropython that is 10 or 20 or more
times faster than piadite which is great
uh and we're very excited about and I
also want to show appreciation for the
community and the people behind by
script so congrats to the core dabs
Fabio Jeff and Paul and thanks to
Antonio Mariano Mador Nicholas and
everyone else that was a part of of this
project and thank you for your uh agents
now think questions
so please if you have any question now
you can ask
[Music]
thank you
um so I saw a question is it callable
for from JS yes
um I didn't actually had manage to show
but uh you know python came now called
JavaScript libraries
um like uh D3 or others for instance uh
and the same from JavaScript you can
actually uh from python unit can expose
your python objects that are usable from
from JavaScript so there's a two-way
communication that you can Leverage
um
do you have another question
uh another question that I see how is
data exchanged with JavaScript uh
highlight has this layer JavaScript
layer and that
um basically python objects become a
python proxy object form in JavaScript
and JavaScript objects become a proxy
object for python but they expose the
same attributes
um so they are transparently callable
from one to the other
foreign
[Music]
not sure I entirely understand the
question
um but if the question is if you can
create panel apps with with pi script
and run on Amazon yes you can run it you
can create panel apps bokeh apps uh uh
Seaborn pretty much most
um
of what's available today Works
um and the piadite the biodine website
actually has a list of packages that
they ported that you should you can look
at okay you can take this question as
the last question how the libraries work
in the browser
um so mostly if it's if they're python
uh pure python libraries they just work
uh and they installed uh via micro pip
which is the tool that is provided by
piodide if there are seed there are
libraries that depend on C or Fortran or
others they need to be compiled uh the
pilot team did a lot of great work
compiling a lot of the pi data stack uh
four Pi for pi ride you can check them
out and they also have instructions on
how to to build those all of the modules
are work except uh things like uh
multi-processed
[Music]
discussion to the Discord
um thank you very much uh we appreciate
you for your talk and for me part of Pi
data Global 2022